hey man say man my name is caskey the
hardest rapper you ain't heard of yet
check me out on the bootleg kev podcast
[ __ ] let's go
bootleg cat podcast special guest
caskey and he brought tasty with him
let's get it guys we in the kitchen you
guys definitely are inseparable at this
point huh all right man we got a formula
that's working right now
welcome thank you bro glad to be here
you've been ducking the show for two
years have i been ducking i feel like
i'm just hard to get a hold of i've i've
you've recorded here like uh i don't
know how many about a thousand times
strict covert restrictions here i had no
copyright
we're the only studio in la with zero
just busted out an interview when i was
recording one time i
got it in yeah that that's how things
work yeah i'm bad at schedules anyway
man uh welcome how's everything uh well
first of all you announced the new album
yep this friday coming out friday 4 29
nobody album drops uh so you've been
working on a lot of music
ut's like a project called jaws yep
and then this album comes like what's
going on yeah i i like uh none of my
fans should ever listen to me when i'm
talking about what's coming out next
because right you know it switches up on
me every day i talk
i kind of got like 10 ideas constantly
brewing in my brain like albums that i'm
working on so like jaws was the project
that i got all my producers on like i
pretty much got like six guys that
they're my go-to guys right including
chalk now so jaws is like the project
with everybody on it um
and it's turning out awesome honestly
it's like half done right now it's sick
but
it's just like it's hard to get
seven dudes from different parts of the
country you know and and lock lives in
germany now so oh [ __ ] jaws put on hold
like i think we're gonna do second
session in uh may but yeah nobody like
me and tasty record damn me every day so
nobody was like let's let's give him
some crack you knocked it out quickly
not really i mean like you know it's
been about six months so some of the
records are like yes yeah some are brand
new but somewhere yeah about six months
because last year you did uh you put out
the project uh with chalk fine art and a
wolf project and then you the wolf
collab project and then you put out like
a hundred dollar mixtape
yeah we did that
which was uh you sold a thousand of them
right thousand copies yeah uh real nipsy
hustle like man shout out nipsey the
goat man you sold so was it all they
were all on usbs right now we did uh we
did um
like 800 physical cds and like 200 usbs
or something like that so nice little
hundred thousand dollar come up yeah you
could say that how like what how did you
decide what to put on the
how did you decide what to put on the
100 project well like the original idea
behind it was like
you know as an artist you got a lot of
music you know i mean you know from
managing artists it's like we record
hundreds of songs and all that nobody
will ever hear yeah and a lot of it's
really dope you know so the kind of idea
was like we still wanted to work on this
album like still working on nobody's
still working on jaws but i don't know
we're just like man like what's a way
that we could like really give people
these records that i don't know if
they'll come out for you know another
year or whatever and so we just like i
don't know we put our heads together the
100 mixtape was 25 songs so
25 records
are they never ever going to be on dsps
and nobody and nobody's uploaded it
online because i wrote everybody a
letter like all thousands came with this
typewriter letter from me that was just
basically explaining to them that this
was like a sacrifice to the creative
gods you know there's like 25 records i
put hours in that i'm not going to put
out they're just for the fans and
no one's leaked no one's leaked it i
still look it up i'm like yeah but we
got the coolest fans man ain't nobody
everybody's a real one they asked me
before they play it for their friends
they'll dm me and be like bro can i show
my homie to the table i'm like yeah rock
up that's crazy quick hunted bag a
hundred thousand hundred on your eggs
it's a nice comment man oh yeah it was
great me and tyson been figuring out how
to get the bag independent i feel like
we've been uh
pretty creative yeah i mean yeah
for artists who are watching this like
what are some of the things that you
have uh
figured out when i mean obviously you do
features
and i love how you address some of those
artists that you do features for on fine
art
i said uh i said uh i never
what i said i never sold out just to i
never made music just to make a deal
except for every feature that i ever did
trying to only be a rapper and pay the
bills but shout out them rappers like
they kept it alive i hope they all
thrive and win my feature price too high
you never could buy it again
you know like
i really do appreciate all the art you
know i know some people maybe look at
the features and it's like
these some of these people ain't on your
level but like i don't know it's all
practice for me and feed the family i
come with the bag i'm happy to get it
bro yeah i've seen a few guys you've
done songs with and i'm like hmm i don't
discriminate the money's blue i'm in
there the money's blue i don't feel like
it like take away from my brand because
i just i make so much music and i i
don't know i'm coming every time like
every single one of those features they
got a [ __ ] they got 10 out of 10
verses and there's always that respect
like for up-and-coming artists no matter
how good they are or whatever just how
they come and i just like get it start
somewhere yeah like that was my first
like i i first my like first foot in the
industry was a paid feature it's
actually jelly bro that was the first
one and the only feature i bought and i
was like my foot in so well was that
like 2012. that was like 2012. yeah i
actually highlight saw me last night and
showed me a video of me and jelly from
[ __ ] nine years ago i was like that's
so crazy because i first met jelly in
2014 13. yeah he was a i paid him like
i hope he's not mad at me for saying
this but i paid him like 250 dollars at
first he was like man [ __ ] it he [ __ ]
with my managers he's like [ __ ] pay for
my studio time and i'll come do it oh
wow
that was like my first like foot in i
guess to the game was that uh before
cash money yeah pre-cash money wow the
song never even came out it's called
they knows like bro i'm in a triple x
white tee riding in these dunks in
florida and [ __ ] like it was
so you put out a mixtape and make a
hundred thousand dollars selling a
thousand copies
allegedly
[Music]
well everyone's gotta get paid off
allegedly we made 100 racks
um
you'll do some features what are the
other things you're doing to shows
streaming i mean streaming bag is you're
making beats too you guys are making
beats
well tasty taught me that he'd make a
crazy bag off of beats and like he's
been teaching me production here and
there and [ __ ] so we put a beat tape
together out we made
uh i'll tell you after the show how much
you mean
you're ducking the irs yeah what's going
on yeah it was a chunk so we made good
money out there streams i mean the wolf
the wolf album increased me and his
pockets about double that wolf album was
uh
a nice little game changer for you you
feel like yeah shout out to yellow wolf
i just want to say he's the only and the
realest artist for being one of the few
that like gave me
public love but also put a bag in my
pocket you know besides birdman ain't
nobody ever done that so right right
right he's real for that big bag
yeah and he doesn't work with like
anyone
nope hell we've been waiting for him and
ritz to put a project out for like 12
years and i wonder if that'll happen
it's never gonna happen we've been
talking about part two
that'll be fire
he's you know he's in his rock mode
right now and i'm in the album mode but
at some point when it's necessary you
know every time i send him a record he'd
be like man who took the lead on those
songs i took the lead as far as i i
chose all the beats like tasty produces
yeah like we pretty much read tasty's
house picking beats out for a couple
days so i came with like the creative
direction as far as like beats and like
what you know i kind of thought
directions were going to be but
i mean as far as the records go it was
pretty much even like wolf the intro
wolf wrote his very right when i played
on the beat he wrote that [ __ ] in about
10 minutes and yeah i feel like wolfe
really brought the bars out of him like
yeah he turned up real tight so it was
pretty i mean it's pretty even as far as
like the writing and [ __ ] went but i i
he kind of like gave me the go-to to
just kind of forefront the direction of
it i feel like lyrically you had your
sharpest year last year because i felt
like fine art was very much like a very
heavy on the bars
yeah like what it was was that when you
know i've been recording myself for a
long time so a lot of times you get in
there kind of freestyle your vibes but
when i was in nashville working on the
wolf album like they record everything
analog and like or like through this
board you know so like no presets on
your vocals so i kind of just had to get
back into like my writing bag and then
just kind of like reminded me like
i'm [ __ ] top tier when i do that you
know so right right yeah i think fine
art and that yeah do you feel like
because i feel like you'd always kind of
been doing anything independently but i
feel like from the beginning of the
pandemic
um
you had the the pandemic brought the
hustle out yo it never was
just turned us up
what the [ __ ] is the name of the we
ain't scared of no police [ __ ] martial
martial
that was like that was our biggest right
i was going to say that was your biggest
record up until the wolf album came out
and it was like thank god because like
my biggest record prior to that was like
a recording you recorded that here yeah
we did that yeah yeah yeah we did that
we did the we like we were recording
here right when the pandemic was
starting to hit yeah and then i was like
yo we should do a [ __ ] pandemic
themed tape we came up with all the song
titles
and then knock that [ __ ] out in like two
days
it's crazy because that song came out
like a month or two prior to all that
like civil rights stuff with the black
lives matter and everything so it was
just we didn't plan none of that it was
just you know
that was like i feel like you were one
of the first guys to um
put a panda everyone had a pandemic
project yeah it had like it kind of got
played out at some point but yeah but
not like do you feel like because i feel
like you've had the best
two and a half years of your career
since the pandemic started or two years
yeah you know what's crazy is that like
my bag kind of slowed at first because
you know like the pandemic hit right
when we were finishing up this tour so
like tour is like a third of the bag
right you know as artists you got like
streams merch and tour so like i felt
like a third of the bag was gone right
and then we just i don't know me and
taysie
are addicted to money so we're like yeah
once some stimulus checks started coming
everybody had money we yeah we just have
features we've taken all the stimulus
money we got every rapper stimulus check
now like honestly it just
it brought the focus back to the music
which was dope and then the wolf [ __ ]
happened like i don't know there was
just a lot of like pivotal things going
on in my life around that time that just
all added up to that we got to stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our sponsors at blue chew the good thing
about blue chew not only does it make
that dick [ __ ]
you know what i mean
get that thing swinging like it never
swing before
but what i love about blue chew is
it's all online man you know usually
when you want to go and get some of that
uh you know some of that good good some
of that blue juice maybe some viagra
first of all it's got the same exact
active ingredients as viagra and as
cialis but you don't have to go into the
doctor's office to get it all right all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com you
have an online consultation and then
they discreetly
send it to you and it's also a discrete
villain you know what i'm saying
it's crazy let me tell you something
maybe you got a first date you want to
make sure you blow them back out that
day you know what i'm saying
pop that blue chew it's a chewable form
some people don't like swallowing pills
ladies are gonna love to swallow you
though once you're on that blue chew
i'll tell you that much bud for sure so
what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg and you're
going to get a month supply of blue chew
for free all right you're going to thank
me later for this the fact that uh the
nilk boys used martial law did is that
what kind of help popped that record
crazy yeah like steve will do it really
love that record
yeah it was like a lot of things you
know the pandemics social media the
protest video was dope it was just that
moment
we couldn't have planned it you know it
just happened you got jessie uh this is
the second video he's been in but this
video he's like she killed it he's like
in the video i've had this idea for like
a minute you know you've seen it with
like the pop star yeah the people were
there i thought that was so funny i've
been wanting to do that for a grip and
jesse and i were tossing the idea he was
down like was it pretty good
he killed it i sent him the lyrics he's
like i got this i'm about to [ __ ]
hold him he loves it he want to be a
rapper or something bro dude we recorded
here but i remember oh
in the booth and he's like yeah i'm just
thinking like more tropical vibes like
oh yeah that's a little more prank was
lit but he's awesome that [ __ ] was
hilarious i like the knuckles i like
jesse good dude jessie's a good dude man
yeah so yeah cause like i feel like did
you barely just meet him during the
pandemic yeah like i had a i met steve
will do it because he's from oviedo
which like my high school
winter springs and oviedo are like rival
schools so like we had some mutual
friends and [ __ ] i knew he was he
brought me out to the noke spot and then
i met them and jesse just he's on my way
blank good dude shout out to florida man
producing steve will do it and caskey
and caskey she would do us a goat man
and mike busey
uh-oh lord of characters bruh [ __ ]
can you tell us about the craziest time
you've had at mike doozy's house uh
no no no no no
honestly like every time at mike what's
the craziest thing you've witnessed
there that you weren't involved craziest
thing i've ever seen well i i just saw
the story post of this lady sucking off
like a thousand veteran dicks yeah that
was pretty much disgusting you were
there for this no it wasn't
something you were there for no i wasn't
there for that uh craziest [ __ ] i was
there i mean just like
crazy orgies with like clowns and
midgets and [ __ ] like that what's that
smell like gross and they're awesome
smells like the gathering of the
juggalos or something it's like a
trailer park playboy mansion
yeah shout out to mike man ibiza is an
absolute legend and honestly one of the
like kindest people to be kindest
biggest got a big heart heart like put
on for me just good dude man solid dude
man let's go back uh how did uh you
initially end up linking with cash money
like what what what was it that you were
doing that put you on birdman's radar
super random couldn't even plan it like
i did this feature for this kid uh
my homie noel kid famous at the time and
he was being managed by dj nasty who was
like
yep good dude did we talk about dj nasty
from orlando yep that's my brother and
uh nasty hit me up and was like yo i got
somebody that want to check you out and
[ __ ] birdman and so bird called me up
one day it was like basically just
because i did this feature record with
this kid he hadn't really heard nothing
of me and he was like man come to miami
i want you to play me some records and
then it was just kind of on and popping
from there
super random super random
birdman offers you a deal what year was
this 2013 [ __ ] yeah yeah
2013. yeah did you even like look at the
contract i sent it off to the lawyer but
i was like yeah whatever it says let's
go like
honestly like bird like our relationship
was different it wasn't like
all businessy and let you know labels
like it was just him being like yo [ __ ]
i want to be a part of your career like
here's a bag
like honestly cash money's been like the
least like i don't know i was blessed
with that situation like they never were
like stricklers on trying to recoup
money from me and just weird [ __ ] like
to be real they just gave me a fat ass
bag and did some things for me so i'm
like because we always hear
the bad things about birds no [ __ ]
cat or like you know my fans will be
like his music's changing because the
cash money birds not putting off you
know all that kind of [ __ ] but like my
real perspective of it is that like you
know i don't think nobody owed me
anything in this world and so to me like
birds did far beyond what he owed me you
know he don't owe me [ __ ] so he gave me
you know 200 racks or something like
that when i was 19. you know i was legit
so
that was super dope 200 bands yeah and
so like they did some other [ __ ] like as
the label for me video shoots and a
couple of things but after that it was
kind of like they were going through the
[ __ ] with wayne streaming music became a
thing so like the whole situation just
kind of changed and like i think they
were still like at this place of like
learning how to navigate the new music
scene because you know it's not the
mixtape era anymore it's like you know
this new era so i think
they're trying to figure that out and i
just kind of did my thing but they just
always gave me freedom to put out the
music i want make the music they never
tripped on you like recouper or nothing
bro they let me put cash money logos on
merch and sell the merch and keep all
the money they bought me a tour bus for
a tour didn't recoup any money off that
like they [ __ ] mean bro so all those
like indie projects that you've been
putting out like that's all you i have
100 of all of that money and i always
have what's your relationship like with
birdman because i know you talked to him
not too long ago yeah we're talking [ __ ]
like it's just good like he's just kind
of like a mentor do you think like if if
you really catch a wave he's going to
call you and be like hey man
yeah yeah and i'd probably rock the [ __ ]
out because to me like he just is
real solid like you know from whatever
people's perspective is on like what the
label could have done but i think people
have this like perception that like a
label could really make you popping and
i think there's more things the label
could have done maybe to be behind [ __ ]
but i'm like you know i think really the
burden falls on the artist and i wasn't
really ready to carry that burden at the
time so you know i was just legit so
there wasn't really much they could have
did i feel like they did a lot and if i
was ready at that time there's also like
a weird white rapper error low-key
like everyone was fighting to be like
the white rapper
mgk was beefing with yellow wolf there's
macklemore
it was just like you know because now
it's like i feel like it's not as like
weird like i'm glad we passed the
macklemore and no disrespect mclemore
great guy nice guy but hey that album
was solid no it was not you're crazy bro
that album was not you're telling me
that album wasn't good wings
come on i did not like one song on that
macklemore ryan lewis i don't wanna hate
on no artists good night it was a great
album no man it wasn't better than
kendrick goodkid mad city but it was a
good body award is it better than kendra
of course not it depends what man
it depends
it depends what metrics were we're
measuring
is that music that i would bump
no but but everybody got different
flavors
so there's no disrespect i'm sure
magdaleno is a really wasn't a bad album
though you said it was a bad album to me
personally just because it's something
you won't listen to that's what makes it
bad to me i don't know i mean i'm not
listening to [ __ ] adele when i drive
around but i'm not gonna call her out
i'm trash you know what i mean but
songs i like
and there's a macklemore song you like
which one there's no way there's not a
single man
play it for me when you first heard
thrift shop you didn't say this it's
kind of funky no i hated it yeah but i
was like
no but i was also not but i was also a
white rapper coming up watching this guy
you know i've had to deal with that a
bunch of times just watching like
another dude blow up that you're just
like what the [ __ ] is this what's going
on right right that wasn't my wave i
wasn't really big on the macklemore but
he's probably a nice dude do you think
back and say to yourself wow i was a
part of the rich gang album one of the
most like pivotal yeah
influential projects ever yeah i was
excited to be a part of the whole
moments where like richome and thug were
popping that's what i'm saying because i
was around all those in those studio
sessions and just like you know miss
that wave it was dope so you were in the
sessions with rich homie and uh and
young yeah they did that like milk marie
one in orlando that [ __ ] was sold they
did that one in the studio uh the studio
that i recorded in orlando yeah i was
there i was there when they made [ __ ]
lifestyles really yeah what was that
like crazy everybody knew it was a hit
bird was like this is the one like we
all just were like who took the lead on
lifestyle as far as like
stuck came up with the medallion
everything yeah he's yeah he did his
thing and then homie laid his first but
yeah that was just that was just a dope
error to be around like i don't know i
was like soaking up game at that time
like just kind of just in all it was
that's a pretty big deal to say you were
at the lifestyle session yeah it was
dope
birdman was here yep everyone knew
yeah yeah like doug had a lot of dope
records like he had bro records that
didn't come out to like slime season
three or four or three that that were
dope um so like he had all these records
playing but they were trying to find
that like real single that took it off
and i don't know berg got a crazy year
for music he was like the second they
made it he was like this is the one we
shooting the video it's over i wish uh
rich homie quan
was
i don't know man you know he got locked
out by his well he got locked out by his
label he was signed to that label nah
what's the real reason why they not
[ __ ] with each other because it was
some person that i don't know i just
mean like he couldn't put out music for
like three or four years so like he just
kind of cooled off why do people listen
to that i would never listen to that if
a label told me i couldn't play music i
would just
change my name or something yeah rich
homie quan and young thug were like they
were like kobe and and uh and shaq back
in the day yeah it was a cool value but
now you got me and yellow well who else
was on who else was technically rich
rallo london on the track uh dorez
deshawn
so dope really dope really slept on dope
artists london that was like dope london
[ __ ] pretty much handled the
production yeah london was killing it i
remember honestly like no knock to my
guys but like i had to when they made
that milk marie record i like had my
guys playing some beats at first
and it was the energy was a little dry
and then london hopped up and went
boom and just the whole [ __ ] room
went oh [ __ ] and
it was out of there that's crazy that's
basically what tasty does now like this
is pretty tasty yeah it's pretty tasty
air so like once i met daisy it was like
yeah it's on damn did you used to work
with any of your old orlando yeah yeah
yeah all my guys and they've all like
improved and gotten really dope like
everybody's on jaws pretty much mass
hector tony choc lock tasty grant angel
hill me
pretty much the whole album yo we gotta
stop the interview real quick tell us
about uh i'm gonna tell you about our
partners in my bookie man make sure you
go to mybookie.ag right now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now
just go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're going to
give you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're going to give you
another thousand to bet with let's go
for the suns all the way just throw all
your money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because jokic is gonna [ __ ]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one
anyway
my bookie.ag my bookie just [ __ ]
google the [ __ ] my bookie use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
deposit free money free money up to a
thousand dollars would you ever sign an
artist i really want to yeah i uh
you know i'm like still uh
fine-tuning and learning the independent
game but i feel like once i really feel
like established and i got like enough
bag that i could put behind the artist
and blow it and it not come back then
i'll i'll dump it in but i got i don't
know i feel like i got a good ear i'd
sign an angel
angel hill yeah he coming on black shout
out to angel hill he's trying to steal
your artists you're coming over man
let's share them
not for real let's get him to not move
to springfield missouri oh my god well
my thing is that my thing is that i
don't like i want to assign
artists that i believe in and just have
like a different type of deal like i
just feel like all the deals that are
going on right now is like either labels
trying to take too much or it's an
advance on your money i feel like
there's ways to sign artists make your
money back make money and then be rich
as [ __ ] so shut up yeah hey listen man i
think
yeah i think like it's always tricky
when you're like a super active artist
uh
still trying to make it to have another
artist under you because it's like i
want to do that you know what i mean i
don't want to feel i want them to feel
hindered by me and also just like
i got a lot of ways to go i'm like
selfish right because you'll see like um
you'll see like an artist they'll be
like yeah i got a label like bro but you
ain't even all the way like there yet
but like your damn self i'm gonna do it
the right way you know yeah it's like i
really want to have that like billboard
here that's why yo gotti is working so
well because
established he wants everyone to be
bigger than him
he's already done it you know i mean
yeah so in time so uh
you go from being on cash money yep
fast forward you drop a tape of yellow
you're kind of like um how how have you
navigated not getting stuck in the
the white rapper box uh underbelly i
feel like everybody in that box knows i
don't belong in that box like this still
try to put them in there nah but like
i'm be real like everybody in that box
at some point or another has
acknowledged that i'm meant to be bigger
than that box you know like all my
homies in that you know i [ __ ] with
everybody in that lane but i don't know
i i mean the birdman looks like jelly
roll broke through the box
broke the box open he broke the box open
i think uh i mean i tried to do my
[ __ ] hardest to just not be
associated with the whole like
that scene but
i don't know it's like the wolf thing
kind of like put me in the dialogue
because wolves like the goat of that
scene yes but every but there's a lot of
people like underwoof that are
just
very much so
i feel like what wolf has done for the
for white rappers as well is really
branched out you know what i mean so
it's dope
he's he's brought you up yeah like i'm
glad if anybody co-signed me it was wolf
because he understands respects the
culture has honored the culture like you
know
i [ __ ] hate the rest of that scene to
be real but yeah i'm not gonna lie like
uh
a lot of that uh [ __ ] is cringy as [ __ ]
man
i'm just like i can't they just hit me
up to have uh
i don't know some [ __ ] dude on some
country ass rapper uh what's his name
up church or something oh i was like
it's a hard pass for me you know
it's a no i don't got any anything
personal to say about a church because
he seems like a nice guy seems like a
dope dude i just can't have no maga
rappers on my [ __ ] shots i just i
don't like any of the blurred lines
between like
i don't know like it's the political
they're ripping up black lives matter
signs all that [ __ ] is crazy like that's
wild to me it's like that dude um i
[ __ ] when i was living in tampa
that [ __ ] weenie [ __ ] who you
were talking [ __ ] to how the uh the fat
guy
the real fat ugly dude with the tattoos
[Music]
i [ __ ] hate this scene bro i'll say
it probably i don't like none of four
jobs blue hair yep and uh he was from
saint pete but nobody in tampa [ __ ]
with him because he was like a goof but
i think he came from like a rich family
or something i don't know
but then all of a sudden
he's like
a trump rapper he's like a trump rapper
here's the thing this is the craziest
[ __ ] i've ever watched a lot of white
rappers and just people in general they
like find this niche that's going and
then they sell out their whole brand for
this they just dig in because it's like
i one thing i'll i'll take being at the
level that i'm at because you know some
of those guys do numbers now or they're
doing a million views but i'll tell you
what i always take being at a lesser
level to keep my integrity high like i
don't have no desire to like hit certain
number accolades or like you know i
think i'm one of the dopest artists out
there and like my whole mission and
pursuit though is just like on my own
artistic path i'll never sell that short
for some trendy like
thing i don't know i just watched all
these low-hanging fruit man exactly i
watched all of them turn from like
street rappers to like trump mega
political rap like that's just mad corny
they're just taking advantage of that
like whole movement there's just people
that are like die hard and this [ __ ] is
atrocious it's like the worst music i
mean to me all that's just trash so it's
annoying that i even get like brought
into yeah i got all these youtube
channels because you beef with those
guys though i didn't beat you but you
put a dis record out which one didn't
you put a disregard nice one what do you
mean which one what the [ __ ] are you no
you guys
what do you what's what are you talking
about i got time today yes hold up now
that wasn't to get me in the dialogue of
of the white rapper [ __ ] that was
because this [ __ ] ass [ __ ] made
another record about that i just was
proven that was like me being in the gym
and just being like hey let me show you
that i'm way better than well those guys
are like really bad at making music so i
don't understand any of it honestly
the whole thing is like i'm just like
it's just like cringe theater rap it's
you know it's like it's like rap that
like you have to watch theater i call it
theater rap because you gotta watch the
video and listen to the [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] they say and then you'll
never listen to the song shout out to
the qa non-rap sub category [ __ ] ollie
up please
please diss me some more so that i can
be separated further from y'all's fan
base i have no desire to be associated
with y'all i don't want to make y'alls
type of music i think all of y'all are
trash and none of y'all could see me on
the mic so
let that
repost that put that up on youtube that
goes for every one of them [ __ ] that
mention my name they'll all all they'll
do is make youtube vlogs about me
because not one of them want to do what
happened to burden again so
there we go
uh you you got a tour coming up in june
55 dates me and doobie
55 days three months it's a long tour
it's the [ __ ] shawn dude
the wife on the tour with you she's
gonna be coming to some of it but three
months it's just like ridiculously long
is that the longest story you've ever
done i've done
i've done like a close i think this is
probably the longest for sure i've done
some long ones like 65 dates or
something like that but it was like back
to back to back so this one's like
spread out over three months but it's a
lot of dates like what is your like uh
top five markets like that that are like
your goals orlando that perform for you
orlando always the craziest like any
florida market tampa orlando crazy in
there uh denver love denver
ohio the whole state super dope
la's dope
salt lake city the mormons [ __ ] with you
woman
a lot of the midwest the midwest is
always crazy because she's like what the
[ __ ] where are we at kansas and there'd
be like 500 people there something just
pop out deep yeah
yeah i'll be all over it what is um like
for you like uh
because i feel like you're kind of uh
have you when's the last time you had
that the 66-day tour you were talking
about
that was like i mean pre-pandemic i feel
like you like
are kind of uh
a lot you've grown up a lot
oh yeah my tour swag is mad different
this time like i'll be up at six a.m and
dude yeah i feel like you're like uh
some adult [ __ ] now yeah i'm gone like i
don't i barely ever see you like super
[ __ ] up or anything i'll be doing that
yeah
i'm just like i'm trying to get a bag
bro i'm trying to like change my i
realized like
i think a big part of my career i was
like feeding into this like i'm a
[ __ ] rock star image you know like we
all kind of want to be that as the star
and it's kind of like this nostalgia of
like i get [ __ ] up i don't have
responsibilities and like the older i
get i just want to take care of my mom
and my sister my nephew and [ __ ] and i'm
like man every time i go out and get
[ __ ] up i'm just
lacking focus i'm missing out on a bag
i'll be setting myself i'd be like
self-sabotaging getting too wasted yo we
got to stop the interview real quick and
tell you about our partners at odd socks
watch this i bet you i got out socks on
right [ __ ] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks all right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're going to save 20 off at
checkout they got so many crazy ass
socks we got twizzlers [ __ ] halloween
uh i mean these are kind of satanic it
just says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like uh
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[ __ ]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon we keep going but what's
most important is odd socks is our
family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleghead podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you could also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [ __ ] right
now all right let's get into the uh
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're going to get back to it
right now did you ever have like a crazy
drug era of life where you were doing it
yeah for sure like i've been i've been
i'm coming up in in july i'll be three
years sober off of hard drugs what was
like your go-to hard drug like molly and
coke molly and coke molly coke and
alcohol and like perks and [ __ ] like
that but
honestly like i didn't like think i was
going that crazy but it was like right
when i met my girl she was like what the
[ __ ] this is your lifestyle and i was
like really started looking at my
lifestyle and i'm like damn i'd be in
the studio till [ __ ] 3 a.m off of
mali i come out and sleep too yeah
drinking every night jesus i think it
was a lot of drinking like that was
probably the biggest so probably a good
way like uh you know with all the
fentanyl [ __ ] going on probably a good
time to yeah i'm out actually yeah rest
in peace i lost a couple on these ashes
three years
sober from hard drugs from yeah all hard
drugs we do not consider psilocybin hard
drugs i was gonna say we did yeah
mushrooms we well like now like i've got
the sober time under my belt so i'll go
celebrate and drink some champagne or
something like that like i'm not
but you're not [ __ ] busting down
rails in the bathroom yeah no i'm cool
on that you know trying to get rich
all the drug energy be like weirdo
energy too the older i get the more i'd
be like y'all a bunch of [ __ ] weirdos
bro like it just drugs make you weird
bro the more time i've had being sober
the more like man i'm focused on my
family my health my music
[ __ ] on maggie rappers and
well leave those guys alone
i just they gonna i've
just yeah just leave him alone but he
wrecked him we did it and like
we made that song in 30 minutes [ __ ] on
his life video and then like all the
other [ __ ] like
calhoun and these [ __ ] weirdos they
just made vlogs about me they don't want
to dis anymore some super weenies man
and that dude's like 50.
i was what's funny is that i made a joke
to my homies like he won't want rap
smoke he'll go make a youtube vlog
that's what he did and i was just like i
won just off of that
i don't know i don't make vlogs about
people
i'm like if i don't like you i'ma just
avoid i'm over here
there leave me the [ __ ] alone they're
over there
[Music]
no part of them
keep all that weirdo [ __ ] away from me
that's why i like you know because like
my guys are like you doobie ritz
sometimes we're like we're like
teetering we're like teenagers
we're from the south we're we're from
well we have some overlapping fans
because i'm from florida we're from the
south white jelly roll's my dog and i
know jelly rolls friends and there's
people that's like yeah like i don't
yeah whoever want to be friends with
them to me i didn't do nothing wrong
like all those [ __ ] came at me
because i said we was the hardest and
shady but i feel like everybody thinks
they're the hardest say they're the
hardest dude like every one of those
guys at some point talk about how
they're the bed like i thought all that
[ __ ] was corny like they tried to like
start some [ __ ] with me
that was all for the internet you know
cause like if you really got an issue
with somebody you're gonna talk to him
you're gonna see him be about some [ __ ]
you know make up edit your [ __ ] vlog
at your house and
[ __ ] spend an hour [ __ ] editing
this clip you um
you got any features on the new on the
new project besides angel hill i got
angel hill introducing the world to your
boy angel hill
he's my favorite one on the tape like i
honestly wolf gave me a 10 out of 10
[ __ ] murder verse that we've been
pocketing for a minute crazy yeah that
rick about to break people's face and
then i got doobie on that
shout out to the dubs man i'll keep my
circle tight there it is uh so the album
comes out on friday and and adam calhoun
by the time this comes out of the i'm
gonna be out so because it's coming out
next week what yeah next week i'm just
playing yeah go get my [ __ ] nobody
go get the that's who's [ __ ] with me
are you gonna put another a hundred
dollar mixtape out and get it grab
another hundred bands [ __ ] right yeah
hell yeah that [ __ ] why not we're not
talking about we're just talking about
it but i was like let's not do it once
you'll do it like once every two years
every two years yeah because then the
fact that once a year it feels like a
cash grab even though i could do that
like i make enough music for sure
definitely a cash crap it's a cash grab
but you're an independent artist to me
it's like the fact you could send me a
thousand of those it's not crazy it's
cash grab is like
saying that it's for money and there's
no value to me it was like a really
innovative way to get the money we
deserve as artists from the people that
was willing to spend that and they got
something really special so i felt like
there wasn't like half-assed songs no we
put our we put hours into that so yeah
well i feel like it was worth it
sold out did you buy one no you cheap
bastard man we couldn't sell it they
sold a thousand of them sorry man
it was gone honestly
yeah i just bought a house so you know
uh anything else going on
bro just honestly music always i'm like
still trying to figure out what's too
much to drop and what's not enough you
know you kind of put a fire under my ass
last year when i was like working on
jaws and i was like kind of going ghost
from everything and just working on jaws
and you were like don't [ __ ] do that
put your foot on that neck and drop you
got to marry i dropped 10 videos this
year already so i'm on it i feel like
you said that to me and i was like
kevin's [ __ ] right let's flood him so
we about to drop like four albums
because i feel like when you have like
the attention man you can't take
advantage of that yeah
i feel like that's low-key where do we
kind of [ __ ] up a little because do we
just do we do we kind of shine
no no he makes timeless music but he
chilled out for like watch his bounce
back bro watch his bounce back
insane he's gonna be fine you guys are
about to tour do 55 i just mean like
he just kind of like disappeared for
like you know i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
honest though i like envy artists like
doobie or like certain artists that i
could think of that have a really big
loyal fan base and they've only dropped
like two projects because i'm the
opposite you know i'm like 12 run that
[ __ ] up man i'm in 12. the way i look at
it is everybody's independent the more
pieces to your catalog you add the more
your residual bag is every month my bag
go up every drop so
that's keep driving until this
we'll go get the album it's out right
now nobody's out tasty
absolute savage my boy tasty beast the
best out in the kitchen
can we get some studio time what's up
later tonight